um it's obviously pride month and you
are someone who's a non-binary person
yeah
um thank you I think that we are in like
a weird uh area of like education when
it comes to like people kind of being
ignorant to what that means and I think
that like there are certain people who
have a hard time adjusting to certain
pronouns and can you kind of just like
if because you uh you also are your she
slash hers one of your pronouns and then
also they them and free ass [__]
free ass [__] the most
important one yes
um for you though like can you kind of I
feel like there should be some etiquette
out there for like people who are still
kind of adjusting especially like in the
hip-hop world I feel like this is all
new like
um why it's important to make sure you
respect someone's pronouns yeah
yeah I mean
you know we are all here having this
Earth Human Experience and we want to
um
be happy in that and be happy in our
identities you know even if I have the
saying embrace the things that make you
unique even if it makes others
uncomfortable and I just live by that
and and and and
I My Hope Is that
as we're having this Earth experience
everybody can understand that we come
from different walks of life some people
are at different evolutions and
discoveries on who they are uh and just
because you may not understand anything
doesn't mean that you shouldn't respect
it right so I think in terms of me being
non-binary
um I think I was not binary a long time
ago I just didn't have the language and
so that's it's important that's why it's
so important to even have certain words
and and a community putting you know the
words to how you're feeling I mean
Prince said it best I'm not a woman I'm
not a man I'm something that you'll
never understand
and I always identify with that word you
know with those words Prince might have
been the first non-binary person listen
he might have been listen so I feel all
of me you know I feel
I feel all of me I honor all of me and
um I see my
um
my spirit and and me outside of the
binary constructs of
I think that's what I think a lot of
people don't understand what it means
right it's right they can Google it it's
very definitely it's it's out it's out
there you know the Google as my uh older
older I would say
I always tell people too like if you're
um so wrapped up on calling somebody the
wrong thing because it makes you feel
better but it makes someone else feel
bad about themselves yeah it's like how
much of an inconvenience is it to like
respect a word like yeah like you're not
asking somebody to like yeah do anything
crazy like just call somebody what they
prefer to be called because if you if
you don't it could potentially you know
make someone feel bad you know yeah yeah
you know compassion uh I think also
education is important yeah you know I
think once we get more educated on um on
what it means and you you really have
conversations with folks you will
realize you may have more in common with
them than you think and
um yeah my hope is that that's why I
love being that's why I love music
that's why I love art that's why I love
making it because what I'm able to do
and what we're able to do is bring
people together right and have these
conversations at concerts you're
learning different things and you know
and I love and happy Pride I don't know
when this is coming out but this is June
it'll be out you know I think we're
dropping the money yeah I love that
we're also in a space where we're
celebrating us unapologetically as you
can see and and sometimes that triggers
and it has as we see with the laws that
are being made right now it's crazy
against you know our my trans family and
lgbtqia plus Community being a part of
that Community imagine me not having the
platform that I have and having to sort
of live in a small town and you know
everybody supports uh anti uh uh uh
lgbtqia plus bills and anti you know uh
trans bills and even being black right
now you know they're taking out black
history in Florida yeah the census of
wild boy man you know horrible horrible
person so you know we have to
is serious like respecting people's it
all matters yes it's funny too because
they're like like I don't want to say
there because I don't like to I don't
like to group anybody in but a guy like
the scientists for example will scream
about how
everything's getting censored like and
everything's like cancel culture but
then you're canceling
like yeah like you know like black
history like in a state it's kind of
crazy it's like
yeah people politicians are are crazy
you have dochi on the album who's one of
my favorite new artists obviously she's
incredible she's incredible yeah
she's a I I I did radio in Tampa so it's
dope to see uh her doing her thing but
she's a person too and she's like very
high level creative like I saw her when
she first time with TD she did like this
like industry performance and it was so
crazy what was it like working with her
all of that like we have kindred spirits
and you know I just as soon as I heard
her music I loved her and I felt her
spirit and then when we met she just
told me how much of an inspiration I was
to her and and watching me gave her you
know a lot of um confidence to just do
her you know
um and you see that you see that she is
somebody who's tapped in you know to uh
her Innovation and what makes her unique
um and I love that about her and and it
was beautiful we were in the studio we
had so much fun making phenomenal like
that song
because when I heard persuasive I was
like oh I love this song I love it and
so when we got together when I was
working on my project I was like oh you
would be perfect for this sort of of of
song and I didn't even tell her I played
her like five songs I don't even tell
her this is a song I want you to be on
she heard phenomenal she's like she
jumped up said hey so she's she's just
humble creative a beautiful person she
came over last night to celebrate with
me oh nice yeah she I didn't even know
she was coming she surprised me so
that's dope